al menos tres personas han muerto hoy
por la mañana después de un ataque con
misiles desde el lado sirio de la
frontera hacia el lado Turco en un
bombardeol que se responsabiliza a las
iepg a las milicias curvas y las de las
yepe que son aliadas del pkk la
guerrilla que llevan guerra desde la
década de los 80 en contra del Estado
Turco y a la que se responsabiliza del
ataque de la semana pasada en Estambul
en el atentado los de los tres muertos
de esta mañana en la localidad de
carcamix dos son un estudiante menor de
edad y un profesor de escuela de hecho
uno de los misiles ha caído encima de
una escuela en esta localidad de carga
mis a pocos metros de la frontera
Consigue a este ataque viene después
como respuesta a los bombardeos y la
campaña de bombardeos iniciada ayer por
la noche por Turquía en contra del norte
de Siria el norte Directo donde hay
posiciones tanto del pkk como las que
estas dos milicias lo han negado Turquía
le responsabiliza de estar detrás del
atentado de la semana pasada en Estambul
por el que murieron seis personas en una
peatonal transita muy transitada calle
peatonal en el centro de esta mujer
dogán el presidente Turco reserva han
hablado después de este ataque con
misiles esta mañana y ha dicho que no
descarta que esta campaña de Aviación
que está diciendo llevada a cabo desde
ayer por la noche pasa a ser una campaña
con soldados sobre el terreno en caso de
que Turquía lo vea necesario ya ha
ocurrido nunca en tres ocasiones en el
pasado y antes de las elecciones
presidenciales de junio de 2023 podrían
ocurrir otra vez Es algo que se estima
que pueda pasar no si no en los próximos
semanas y en los próximos meses